WE EVOLVED SINCE LAST TIME WE
CAME OUT OF ALL-STAR BREAK.
IT FEELS GOOD BUT WE KNOW THE
JOB ISN'T FINISHED.
>> Jared: ON A PERSONAL NOTE,
YOU SAID YOU WERE FASTING FOR
RAMADAN, FOR THOSE THAT DON'T
KNOW, NO FOOD OR WATER, SUNUP TO
SUNDOWN.
HOW DO YOU GET THE ENERGY TO
SCORE 34 POINTS WITH VERY LITTLE
NUTRITION IN YOUR BODY?
>> IT IS A JOURNEY WITH GOD.
AND I'M NOT ALONE IN THIS.
I HAVE BROTHERS AND SISTERS
AROUND THE WORLD FASTING WITH
ME.
WE HOLD OUR PRAYERS AND
MEDITATIONS SACRED.
WHEN YOU COME OUT HERE, GOD IS
INSIDE ME, YOU, ALL OF US.
I AM WALKING WITH FAITH.
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
WHEN I GET A CHANCE TO DO THIS
IN THIS TYPE OF ARENA AND
SHOWCASE MY TALENTS GRANTED TO
ME STRICTLY FROM GOD, I AM
HUMBLED.
>> Jared: SCORING 34 IN A MUST
WIN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Brian: THANK YOU, JARED.
KYRIE IRVING.
WE SHOULD BE MORE POSITIVE, TOO,
STAN.
WE'LL BE THAT WAY THE REST OF
THE PLAYOFFS.
NO FASTING ON OUR PART THOUGH.
>> Stan: DO I LOOK LIKE I EVER
FASTED?
>> Brian: FOR STAN VAN GUNDY,
JARED GREENBERG AND THE RE